hi reg how are you Theodor can you
answer this question for me because I do
not know bedding whatsoever if Tiger was
as you mentioned sixty one two or three
months ago and you locked in that bed
and today he's 16 to 1 and he goes on to
win the Masters do you collect on the 62
one if that was what you were locked
into or yes but a lot of a lot of people
do that at the beginning of the season
with NFL or college basketball or even
college football where you just lock in
on somebody that you think is gonna be a
sleeper and you're able to you know
sometimes it pays big phil mickelson i
think he bet on the Ravens didn't he
Paulie pre season when they won this
Super Bowl yes he got the preseason
Superbowl Ravens bet when I used to come
on our show and do picks yes and he won
a couple hundred thousand dollars there
all right what else is on your mind reg
college basketball my goodness this is
an ugly look for the NCAA and college
athletics because let me just start by
saying this please people don't bury
your head in the sand and just think
this is an exclusive just a basketball
because I guarantee this is going on in
football I guarantee this is going on in
baseball and finally I think what the
FBI probe has done has shed light on how
big a business college athletics
actually is but I don't know what we do
with it reg I know that it goes on and
just because it goes on in football
doesn't mean it's okay to go on anywhere
but I don't I don't know what happens
here you know Jay Bilas said why not
just have you know open market here
where we're just gonna bid on you to
bring you in you know this is the sad
thing about this because I've been
racking my brain trying to come up with
solutions and I guarantee you I bet the
NCAA has as well far more smarter people
than you and I and even Jay have
probably wracked their brain saying what
is a solution because every time I say
well
hey just pay the the basketball the
football and the baseball players well
what about the women's softball team
what about the women's lacrosse team
what about the women's basketball team
if I'm Geno Auriemma and the UConn women
when I think of college basketball at
UConn I think of the women's team not
the men's team so how are you gonna pay
in a top recruit to come to UConn and
some of the girls are over there like
what are you doing paying this dude and
we're we're the ones that are winning
championships so it is a slippery slope
you know we could talk about all the
ones and Duns one thing I do like
because I've been to a lot of college
campuses and games I see a lot of
jerseys floating around there with the
young men's and women's names on there
why can't they get a piece of that
yeah I'm fighting with in the
merchandising yeah I mean even fine with
in yeah yeah why has not ever been in
play I don't know I think the NCAA wants
to come up with some kind of solution
that doesn't cost the n-c-double-a any
money or you know the via you know
they're making billions off March
Madness but I I don't I don't know if
they want to come up with a solution
here and I don't know if anything
happens here unless Sean Miller goes to
prison for you know this hundred
thousand dollar loan and the FBI
wiretapping him I'd like to hear that
conversation of how that went down but I
don't know if anything changes here it's
still money with the shoe companies
coach is tied into the shoe companies
you got schools tied into the shoe
companies you got AAU coaches the movers
shakers the fact the fact that a coach
will go I'm gonna hire your coach and
another assistant coach just to get you
to go to my college for one yes that's
what I have a problem with them all
right they always try to bury their head
in the sand and they know this is going
on and then when the FBI comes out and
says they have wiretaps they have a
muddy trail then they get all wide-eyed
and be like oh my goodness what is going
on here
stop it stop it here's the problem if
you start paying young men and young
women how far back do you go because
these kids are starting to get recruited
at 13 14 and 15 so how much is enough
and bigger schools Ohio State UCLA USC
Michigan North Carolina did they've got
deeper pockets thinking that famous
alumni I mean it when does it ever stop
that's why they're really I mean what is
this there is no solution I mean I
understand what Jay is saying open it up
free enterprise but what is enough when
your top recruit at Ohio State is
driving around in a BMW I I don't know
how you stop it
he's Reggie Miller in the hall of famer
he's in Portland this Thursday night I
love Portland 10:30 love it
Timberwolves and the Trail Blazers with
Kevin Harlan and an Allie LaForce I do
see would you play the LeBron James
comments after the loss yesterday's San
Antonio Spurs I mean I think we had a
point protect the shooter more than a
driver there's no reason I should be
going to the line four times in a game
when I Drive a hundred times to the pain
I'm getting hit and slapped and grabbed
and whatever whatnot so well we protect
the shooter that's what that's what it's
turned into you know chicks dig the long
ball and was about right what is LeBron
saying here we officials I said we the
media but really the officials they
officiate LeBron much different than
they probably do the rest of the players
because for so many years he's been the
biggest the baddest the strongest and
you can't call a foul on every single
drive by LeBron James and I looked at
the numbers he has gone to the line the
least amount of times since his rookie
season and this year and I agree with
him he's not settling for jump shots
he's become a much improved jump shooter
but he still put the ball on the deck
and let me get to the hole and use my
strength and the fact that he's only
going to the lines four and a half five
times is kind of ridiculous so I see his
point but that's the way the league is
now because they do want to protect the
jump shooters because
we're a jump shooting league that brute
strength he would be averaging 10 to 15
free throws in the late 80s 90s easily
but but how are we protecting the jump
shooters here Paulie would you run down
the guys who have the most free throws
attempts this year James Hardy in the
bar yeah Yanis is that the combos number
two yeah that's he's not a jump shooter
these are guys who go to the hoop the
harden gets found you know I mean he'll
initiate contract or you know he'll fool
you into you know running into him but I
mean he's driving all the time these are
jump shooters who are getting these
fouls called well I would say this they
officiate him differently because when
you stack up LeBron James versus Harden
and on tidak kupo he just he's a man
chill he's a man now but before he's
always been that man-child he's always
been bigger than everyone the same way
was was back with MJ or with magic or
bird those guys got styled just about on
every possession but you can't call
every possession but I'm trying to
figure now I do agree that they don't
know how to officiate LeBron they didn't
know how do you officiate Shaq it feels
like it feels like he's lobbying for
something here like hey I just wanna you
know when you put that little whisper in
the officials hear about hey you know
he's holding me and then next time down
then he calls holding on the guy feels
like that's what LeBron is doing it'll
be interesting the last I believe they
have 20 to 23 games left to see if his
free throw attempts attempt to rise up
as he enters the playoffs because look
he's lobbying for the big picture come
playoff time he wants to get to the line
LeBron should be at the line eight to
ten times a game yes easy I have no
problem with him yes with his makeup and
how he plays the game he should be at
the line eight to ten times a night but
he does settle for the jumper far more
that he did than his rookie year yeah I
mean you mentioned that these are the
fewest free-throws since his rookie year
he he's not afraid to take a pull-up
jumper and he never did that before he's
not but the end of the day his game is
his head down and getting all the way to
the rack mm-hmm I don't think I don't
think we're looking I think we're
officiating LeBron differently I don't
think we officiate jump shooters
differently I think LeBron wanted to put
the blame on something else instead of
saying I'm I'm not getting the calls
that I should be getting and it's just
about me now all of a sudden like jump
shooters I just don't hurry Steph
Curry's the best jump shooter pervy the
game has ever seen and he goes to the
line what three times yeah
six he goes entwine six times I'm
surprised at that he and LeBron are tied
well that's ridiculous that is
absolutely ridiculous
so I see LeBron pointing
yeah but step goes to the hoop - it's
not like just a stand alone shooter not
he goes he goes to the hoop but not like
LeBron James Rawlings is carrying two or
three defenders with them every time to
the hoop yeah I understand that we don't
know how to officiate him just like Shaq
I get that and you made a great point
that you're right because we did not
know Shaq changed the room first of all
will changed it then Shaq changed it
because how do you officiate guys that
are that big and that strong what was it
like to found Shaq oh my god it no not
necessarily foul Shaq back when you had
to go across and do cross screens they
don't even do that now it was risked
this open so it was the shooting guard
it was my job on a cross five to go
across and they say put a body on Shaq
and I would look at Larry Bird I was
looking at Rick Carlisle I'll be like
you always do my best at 185 you want me
to put a body on Jack like you would
just like toss me away so I started to
like use a little bit of elbows maybe a
little bit of a leg whip to try to get
Rick open but it was like comical trying
to put a body on Shaq yeah a couple of
things I wanted to ask you about Isiah
Thomas said he was traded from the Cavs
to the Lakers because Cleveland was in a
panic mode what do you make of that
agree look this guy was falling in
Cleveland
and that locker room was very toxic and
not to put it all on Isaiah Thomas but
something was going on where changes had
to be made and it's funny how the
reactions after the trade when they won
their first two and Cleveland was a
clear-cut favorite now they've gotten
younger this is exactly what LeBron
needs and then they lose a couple games
the skies back to falling in Cleveland
and those are the X patient's
expectations that are gonna come with
playing with LeBron James I knew that
you knew they were gonna be on a
honeymoon period with the trade but I
kept telling people look I want to see
when the bills come in from the wedding
when they hit a little bit of adversity
because they've gotten guys that are
great and younger don't get me wrong but
not a lot of playoff experience other
than what maybe Rodney hood who went to
the playoffs interview once with Utah so
let's kind of temper our expectations of
Cleveland to me it's still Toronto and
Boston and then Cleveland yes they've
got LeBron James and you got to beat
that dude oh wait you've got Cleveland
third on the list if I said who are you
picking to go to the finals in the East
I would still pick LeBron James but it's
not as close as people are saying
because people don't give join Casey in
Toronto a lot of credit and rightfully
so but they play up north and no one
sees them but man they're prime they are
prime just right it's not it's not sexy
to pick them at all I know because we
because we know their resume in the
playoffs every year look they're built
for their regular season 50-plus games
are gonna be in the top three and then
come playoff times Kyle Lowry fizzles
demar derozan plays great but shoots
25% I mean we know their resume but this
year is different because they changed
their style up they're no longer your
turn my turn type of team it's better
ball movement and Dwane Casey needs to
get serious serious consideration for
coach of the year I think Quin Snyder
might be your coach of the year yes yes
if they continue to win if they make the
playoffs yes I will take
it's a lot like erik spoelstra last year
in Miami remember Miami yeah wait how to
play often they made that late push to
almost get to that a seed and got along
a strong consideration for Erick's for
the same thing for Schneider but Dwayne
Casey right now would be my coach of the
year do you have any problem with teams
tanking without the owner telling you
they're tanking because Chicago is
tanking now you know they decided they
want to play when you say I want to play
the younger players see what they can do
you're basically saying we're we're
going to tell you thank you yeah I'm not
gonna use the word tanking I've always
had a problem with it because to me it
shows the integrity of the game and for
teams that are vying for playoff
position especially if you're six seven
or eight in the east or west and you're
playing one of these chicago or brooklyn
nets or you know one of these teams that
you know are clearly looking towards the
future that affects playoff seeding
because you're not playing the best team
on the floor it goes towards the
integrity of the game and your
commissioner needs to do something about
that it's just not fair yeah the teams
are doing it and they did it in baseball
the Astros did it the Cubs did it they
end up winning a World Series we
complement the Sixers with the process
they call it the process instead of
thanking it sounds a lot nicer you know
this is the process but you know what
the Mavs did is is tanking what Chicago
is doing now and I'm sure there's other
teams that are doing the same thing it
just cuban got burnt because he was
forthcoming with dr. j on his podcast
and i think that's why i come draft time
you you need to open it up now into the
teams with the worst records but the
teams that are actually continuing to
fight like san antonio Golden State I
mean they're doing things the right way
Houston Denver
I mean teams that are in the middle of
it that are fighting and worked and have
done a great job drafting and developing
young players just don't give the teams
with the worst workers the best odds to
you know win the lottery opened it up
yeah reg we'll be in Portland come out
and say hello to Reggie
10:30 Eastern the Timberwolves and the
Blazers coming up Thursday night Kevin
Harlan and Allie LaForce with the call
their safe travels is always rent I
appreciate a Theodore thank you guys
Dennis love y'all as use that's a Reggie
Aloysius Miller jr. that therefore more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]